When people talk about AI coding tools,
they usually talk about one thing,
speed, rapid prototyping, vibe coding,
spinning up things in a flash. And sure,
that's part of it, but it's not all of
it, and it's not the most important
part. An AI agent is just another tool
in your tool belt, like a debugger or
autocomplete. And like any professional
tool, you need the skill to master it.
So, in this video, I'm going to show you
how to use Dreamflow to go beyond simple
prototypes. We're going to prompt
Dreamflow to set up real production
architectural patterns. I'll show you
how to prompt like an architect so you
can build code bases that will last.
Okay, so let's jump into DreamFlow here
and we're going to create a new project
right here. And it's just going to be a
habit tracker. So, we're just going to
call it habity.
Create project. And when you create a
project, we're just running Flutter
create under the hood to scaffold out a
basic app. Okay, so here's my scaffolded
out app. I've got my agent open over
here. Now, the main thing you want to do
when you're building with AI is you want
to work in small iterable and testable
steps. So, I'm going to just start out
by creating some of the files and
folders. So I'm going to say I would
like to create a habit tracker app using
layered architecture and provider for
state management. So I want the agent to
create the files and folders but don't
write any of the code yet. And then I've
got this architectural diagram that I'm
just going to paste in a real basic app
right there and send it off. Now, as
that's working, let's open up our code
view right here. And you can see that
it's building out all of these files,
but with no content in them. And that's
great. That's exactly what we want to
see. Okay, great. The agent is finished.
We get a summary of the project
structure, which is exactly what we
passed in. That's great. And we can see
all of our files and folders here. And
we can look into them and see that
they're not actually populated with any
code yet. That's great. I'm also going
to tell the model, I want you to add
these architectural decisions
in an architecture.md
file. And I'm doing this so that as I'm
working, it's always referencing the
architectural decisions that we've made.
Okay, great. The agent has created this
file. And if we go into it right here,
we can see it's going to be layered
architecture. We're using provider and
we've got some data regarding the file
structure. Okay, that's beautiful. So,
we've got this project set up and let's
say we wanted to build out another
feature. Now, of course, I could ask the
agent to do this or I can do some of the
work myself. So, let's say I want to add
a feature for a new motivational quote
each day. Well, first I would need to go
into my services to add a quote service.
So, I can just go into here and I can
rightclick on service. I'm going to add
a file right here and I'm going to call
it quote service.dart. Then I'm going to
need a provider for that. So let's add a
file here for our quote provider.
And finally a widget for this. And I'll
just do the same thing. Daily quote
card. Now obviously the next step I
would want to go into my main.dart and
add this to the multi-provider. I would
need to add that new widget on our home
screen. But you can see the pattern of
how we would build here in a way that's
scalable and maintainable. Not just
passing off one prompt to build the
whole app. So let's take another example
and this time let's do a slightly more
complex architecture and slightly more
opinionated decisions here. So we're
going to do another habit tracker and
it's going to be habit complex. Let's
create that project.
Okay. So for this app I'm going to say I
want to build a habit tracker using
featurebased architecture. I'm going to
use riverpod for state management. Go
router for routing. Do for networking.
Freeze and JSON annotation for data
modeling and serialization. shared
preferences for simple storage and Intel
for internationalization and
localization. Now, same thing as before,
I don't want you to write any of the
code, just create the files and folders
and add dependencies to the pubspec.
Okay, great. Now, let's just add the
architectural diagram and send it off.
There we go. Adding all the
dependencies. That looks great. Checking
the pubspec. Okay, that's great. Let's
check out the file structure. We've got
our features, just one feature for now.
Our posts with our three layers right
here. That looks beautiful. Now, if I
were to continue working on this
project, I would probably delegate the
agent to configuring the basic routing,
setting up provider scope, then maybe I
would focus on the domain layer of our
first feature habits. And once again,
the idea is working in small, iterative,
and testable steps. So the big idea is
that by prompting Dreamflow with
specific architectural patterns and
libraries, we've laid the groundwork for
maintainable production applications,
not just throwaway prototypes. This
isn't vibe coding and it isn't magic.
These are powerful force multipliers,
but their output is a direct reflection
of your input. A vague prompt gets you a
vague result. A professional,
architecturally aware prompt gets you a
professional codebase. And this
fundamentally elevates your role. You
spend less time on the tedious setup and
more time on what really matters, the
high-level design and the core logic of
your app. It shifts the essential skill
from just knowing how to code to knowing
how to communicate a complex system. So
remember this process. Think like an
architect. prompt in clear iterative
steps and review the output constantly.
Treat the AI agent not like a magician,
but like a junior developer who's fast
and smart, but needs your direction and
review. You are the lead architect.
Mastering this conversation is a new
essential skill for developers, and it
will save you countless hours of
refactoring down the line. Thanks for
watching the video, and we'll see you in
the next one.
[Music]